John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. I'm
actually at a minigolf course. I wish you
were here but you're busy, like, interviewing
the President or whatever. Oh wait.
Hank: I'm in Florida where this happens.
J: It's Question Tuesday, the day that we
answer real questions from real Nerdfighters
while also playing minigolf. Are you nervous
about interviewing the President of the United
States?
H: Thanks for bringing it up.
J: Are you?
H: Yes. I'm trying to golf.
J: But is it going to affect your golfing?
John and Hank's mother: It absolutely is.
H: Apparently.
Mom: Oh.
J: Oh, oh, oh, oh! That was terrible. Why
do you look so much taller than me? It must
be because there's something wrong with the
ground. Anyway, what's your favorite flightless
bird?
H: You're my favorite brother.
J: Hank just got a hole in one, but I insisted
that he tapped it twice because I don't want
to get too far behind and I'm the big brother
and that's how we compete. I may not be better
than you, Hank, but I am able to change the
rules mid-stream. Are you behind me?
H: What are you...
J: Nothing. There's a ton of waterfalls in
this joint. If your last name were any other
color what would it be?
H: Oh, chartreuse.
J: (Laughs) I would go with blue which I think
is a kind of chartreuse. The next question
is will you try on each other's glasses and
I think we should do that and putt-putt.
H: Ooh.
J: Hank's prescription is actually pretty
close to mine. I feel fairly comfortable.
H: Yours are just mostly dirty. Oh my God,
John. I don't clean my glasses very often
but that's just disgusting.
J: Can he perform under the pressure of wearing
his brother's glasses? It's Hank Green, it's
Hank Green! Oh no!
H: There it is. Werdegerdeh.
J: Oh, Oh! Come on! Give me that bounce!
H: That was a good bounce.
J: Between the two of us, who was weirder
in high school?
H: Oh, I don't know. me? I feel like me. You
had all those friends.
J: Who's better at rhyming?
H: I don't know but I have pretty good timing.
J: Sorry, I was trying to think of a rhyme
for timing. I didn't get there. Diming? Fliming?
Climbing! Goh, it took me a minute. Hank might
be better. Who's your favorite member of One
Direction?
H: Let's go with the police officer guy.
J: I like the construction worker, you know.
H: Yeah. I feel it.
J: They're all good though. I love that song.
H: Yeah.
H & J: "YMCA. It's fun to stay at the YMCA."
J: What should win the Oscar for Best Picture?
H: I'm gonna go with The Fault In Our Stars,
John.
J: Not nominated. Um, I'm gonna go...
H: You look like the TFIOS clouds right now.
J: I know, it's a... marketing. Never not
marketing. I'm gonna go with Whiplash or Selma.
I thought that both those were excellent.
Hank, how do you feel about koalas?
H: They poop in their sleep.
J: Is that true? Can you play the ukulele?
H: No. Yes, I can play, like, two chords.
J: I can't play it at all. And what's your
favorite type of hummus?
H: Uh, chickpea.
J: I didn't know there were types of hummus.
H: It's the final hole and we are tied.
J: Oh, it's tense, very tense.
H: Eighteen.
J: Hank is significantly closer than I am.
H: For the tie.
J: No!
H: Oh! Oh, oh no! How does it feel to be less
good than me?
J: I'll see you on Friday.